next voicemail back
hey michael listen i'm not a misogynist
let me put that out of the way first but
i just want to know what is your opinion
as to why women have gotten so picky and
entitled when it comes to finding a man
some of them will say that they won't
date anyone who's under six foot five
some won't date anyone that makes under
20 billion dollars a year and someone
date anyone that doesn't look like
leonardo dicaprio why have women become
like this i think it's kind of unfair
where if i say i don't want to date a
woman that's fat i'm all of a sudden a
misogynist and that is my only parameter
of women i'm not gonna date so yeah why
do you think women became like this and
how can we kind of change that because
there's too many women on my timeline
complaining about not finding men but
doing this at the same time thank you
i knew this was going to be a good
question when it opened with look i'm
not a misogynist to nothing but
how come i can't say that a woman's fat
and i don't want to date her but she can
uh you know i think
men and women have always had a little
bit of a problem understanding one
another they've wanted different things
it's always good first to take a look at
the man in the mirror and see there's
maybe something wrong on your side but
you are identifying a real problem that
i think is actually particular today you
see people delaying getting married you
see people dating lots more people
before they ever settle down i think the
reason for that is swipe right culture
i think the reason for that is not just
women but men too
are are viewing one another as
expendable or viewing one another as
replaceable as and of course because the
way we date now is we just look on a
phone and everyone looks pretty much you
know they're all in the same context and
we just go boom boom boom boom and
there's an endless supply of them and
and so
this is one of the it's how people date
now so i'm not discouraging it entirely
but this is one of the perils of online
dating is that you you just you reduce
people to their individual features
their height their looks their
their hair color or their whatever
their resume even that they put on some
of these personals ads on the dating
apps and you don't look at a human being
as a cohesive whole as something special
something
something and someone that is unique and
get to know them and so it's just i got
it one date monday one day tuesday one
day thursday and you keep you keep
moving on no you're talking to real
human beings recognize that you're
dealing with eternal people and you're
gonna have to see those people in heaven
someday if you're lucky buster did you
like that clip i'm glad you did make
sure you ring that smash and like that
subscribe and click that doodad and hit
the gizmo that way you will get all of
the notifications for the michael
knowles show you should also go to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
make sure you head on over there and
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]